[Music]
after more than 35 years Michael Keaton
makes his return as Beetlejuice with
Jenna Ortega by his side the cult movie
established Tim Burton as a top director
for fantastic films once and for all in
1988 followed by works such as Batman
Edward Scissorhands and Sleepy Hollow
now the sequel Beetlejuice 2 is finally
to be released well-known stars from the
classic will return but there will also
be famous new cast members in this
preview we'll give you all the current
information enjoy
the first part was about the Poltergeist
Beetlejuice who was supposed to assist a
deceased couple in driving away the new
family in their house however as he
turns out to be an extremely unpleasant
contemporary the two must do everything
they can to stop Beetlejuice in doing so
they are supported by Lydia the daughter
of The house's new residence in the end
they succeed in putting the Poltergeist
in his place and Lydia embarks on a new
life together with the ghost couple
regarding the story of Beetlejuice 2 it
is already known that the Poltergeist
and Lydia will meet again her daughter
is also expected to play a key role in
the plot there was already a lot of
speculation on the gnat as to who the
father will be and whether Beetlejuice
himself has something to do with it
after all he even went into marry Lydia
in part one marriage also seems to be a
topic in the sequel first pictures from
the set show for example leading actress
Jenna Ortega in a pink wedding dress
while mother Lydia still prefers a dark
look given the crazy backstory a very
normal life seems rather improbable the
one or other Voodoo witchcraft will
surely play a role and the predecessor
already made it clear that Lydia
possesses certain super natural Powers
she can communicate with Spirits after
all
fans of Beetlejuice can look forward to
a reunion with some familiar faces
Batman actor Michael Keaton returns as
the titular Poltergeist although there
was criticism that a ghost could hardly
look 35 years older Keaton noted that he
already looked like he was 150 years old
beneath all that makeup stranger things
Star Winona Ryder is also back as Lydia
the role that helped her break through
in her career in the late 80s Catherine
O'Hara played Lydia's mother in 1988 and
is also returning the currently biggest
name of the cast of Beetlejuice 2 is
certainly Jenna Ortega who is not only
impressive in Scream 5 and scream 6 but
also achieved a lot of Fame in Tim
Burton's Wednesday Series in Beetlejuice
2. she will play Lydia's daughter also
cast our big star such as Willem Dafoe
and Justin Thoreau by the way
Beetlejuice seems to have gotten over
Lydia in the meantime as none other than
Monica Bellucci will play the life of
the crazy tease nothing is known about
the involvement of the other two main
actors from part one namely Alec Baldwin
and Gina Davis here it might be more
difficult to explain the 35-year age
difference between the ghost couple but
we are excited to find out whether there
will be at least small Cameo appearance
the team behind Beetlejuice 2 sounds
very promising Tim Burton will once
again be responsible for directing the
movie and implementing a script by
Alfred Guff and Miles Miller the two
previously wrote Wednesday for Netflix
Danny Elfman a longtime friend of Tim
Burtons who was composed of music for
many of his films including Burton's
Batman films Edward Scissorhands and the
first Beetlejuice will again provide the
score the film is being produced by Brad
Pitt and his production company Plan B
filming began in the summer of 2023
partly at the same locations as the
previous film however due to the actors
strike in the United States they have
been suspended for the time being
based on the latest plans Beetlejuice 2
is scheduled to open in theaters on
September 6 2024 and should once again
provide both scares and laughter in one
film according to main actor Michael
Keaton the film should be in no way
inferior to the original in terms of
humor and offer a similar amount of fun
we can't wait to see it what do you
think are you optimistic that the sequel
will match the quality of the original
are you fans of Tim Burton and if so
which one is your favorite movie let us
know in the comments
[Music]
thank you foreign